نعم بالفعل المعارك ما زالت متواصله
تحديدا في منطقه جباليا حيث ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يبدو انه يقوم بعمليات توغل
بين الحين والاخر وواضح هذا من خلال سحب
الدخان التي تتصاعد من اكثر من موقع في
منطقه جباليا نحن نرصد اكثر من موقع
تتعالى فيه سحب الدخان في منطقه جباليا
وهذا يؤشر على حجم العمليات وحجم
الاشتباكات التي ما زالت مستمره في جباليا
والتصدي من جانب ايضا المقاومه الفلسطينيه
للقوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
على وجه التحديد لا تنتهي بمعنى ان
الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره وما زالت قويه
وهي تذكر حقيقه في الايام الاولى للعمليه
البريه او لوصول القوات الاسرائيليه
تحديدا الى تلك المناطق العمليه هنا على
اشدها وهي متواصله وواضح بان ربما نمط
العمليات العسكريه قد اختلف لكن الزخم
العسكري ما زال على حاله سواء كان ذلك من
خلال الغارات الجويه
[موسيقى]
شاهدنا اذا للتو عمليه
اعتراض اذا كانت هذه عمليه اعتراض ل احد
الصواريخ التي يبدو انها اطلقت من المنطقه
الشماليه لقطاع غزه
شاهدتم هذا الان في بث مباشر نعم حيث ان
منظومه القبه الحديديه يبدو انها اعترضت
احد القذائف الصاروخيه التي اطلقت من قطاع
غزه هذا ايضا يشير الى ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على
اي توجيه هذه الصواريخ باتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه الغلاف واحيانا هذه
الضربات الصاروخيه تمتد الى داخل العمق
الاسرائيلي الى المدن الكبرى رغم ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال يعمل وبكثافة